franki grande gives an update on ariana
since her split from Pete Davidson and
the death of her ex Mac Miller are a
mystery well he caught up with Frankie
while on the red carpet at Bette
Midler's Hulu in bash in New York City
where he opened up about his little sis
and how the family has been supporting
her during this difficult time we just
had a game night
together the other night was me Mommy
and Nona and we just had like a great
time mommy won it was space time mommy
won but it's because she's working
really hard and you know like getting
prepped for tour
[Music]
so I'm picking it up picking it up
and another whole ball like it's too
much lots of stuffs going on
so she's doing wicked and that's the
dodged in the wicked 15th anniversary
[Music]
if Ariana doesn't play Elphaba then I
think there's something seriously wrong
with the world you know she's perfect
Orianna is Elphaba come on truly crazy
[Music]
but I swear celebration throughout us
that's all to do
[Music]
[Applause]